[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man
and today Marvel officially released a
never-before-seen alternate post-credit
scene but 2008 iron man that has a lot -
impact from it the clip which lasts
roughly 1 minute not only features
references to the Hulk but also
spider-man and the x-men I'm gonna play
the clip in just a second as it's kind
of crazy looking back at how it hints at
the original plans for the MCU and how
the companies look like they may have
all been working together which in light
of the recent Sony Disney situation
reiterates how difficult it may be to
put a shared universe together with so
many properties being owned by companies
that are competing with each other the
clip is from the new infinity saga box
set that's being released this year and
features an introduction from Kevin
Feige who discusses it in more detail so
let's get into the clip that we said
will never show this to anybody put it
away
we're bringing them out we're putting
them on this disc and I'm about to show
you a deleted scene that has never been
seen by anyone before right now thank
you again so much and enjoy
[Music]
as if gamma accidents radioactive bug
bites and assorted mutants weren't
enough I have to deal with a spoiled
brat doesn't play well with others and
wants to keep all his toys to himself
the alien Nick Fury director of shield
I'm here to talk to you about the
Avenger initiative Oh what are we
avenging whatever the hell we want okay
so there's a lot to impact from the clip
firstly a reference is the Hulk who at
the time only had the angley solo film
which is pretty much cast to one side in
light of the Incredible Hulk reboot
which was tied to the MCU and has pretty
much become the established origin story
for the character for those of you who
don't know Hulk is actually owned by
Universal however they allow the
character to appear in MCU movies as
long as it's a team-up film but as
they've never went on to develop any
solo films featuring the character we've
never really got an eventual end to the
arc that was set up with the leader and
so on the clip also most interestingly
name drops the x-men and spider-man who
were at the time owned by Fox and Sony
respectively the fact that these three
entities are mentioned and the Hulk
eventually came to be in the MCU
highlights to me that Marvel may be
negotiating with the companies at the
time to include their characters in
their shed universe though as the clip
never got included in the final cut it's
pretty safe to say that negotiations
probably fell apart with neither company
other than Universal wishing to part
with their properties it's actually
crazy that at one point there were plans
to have the MCU integrated with the Fox
and Sony Universe so we could have had
Tobey Maguire Hugh Jackman and Robert
Downey jr. on screen at the same time
which yeah I would have loved to have
seen now but I guess the studio's just
couldn't work things out this is a real
shame as we all know the way that the
Hulk was used in the MCU was incredible
with him arguably becoming one of the
best characters in the entire roster
still this is an awesome little scene
that just flashes
how Graham marbles plans were at the
time and how they've always wanted to
pull together all of the Marvel
characters into one streamline Cinematic
Universe to have them all working
together it's kind of a bittersweet clip
as I would have loved to have seen the
original x-men cast alongside the
Avengers but I guess we must be in the
wrong timeline right now if anyone has
like a quantum GPS or a time stone do us
a favor and go back and change this cuz
it would have just been amazing
obviously and loved hear your thoughts
on this and if you would have liked to
have seen all of them in the same film
or if you're happy that Marvel had to
really pull together there be and
c-listers to make the MCU what we have
now comment below and let me know and if
you enjoy this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the first announcement of casting
news that we have for the MCU x-men
movie if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books then you can follow me on twitter
at definition whitey it's the best way
to get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this also just wanna let you
know that we're giving away a free copy
of spider-man far from home on blu-ray
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
alternate post-credit scene in the
comments section below the winner will
be chosen at random on October the 15th
and the blu-ray I'll be shipped out from
the end whoever gets the prize it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]